はい では第2部に入ります
第2部は全体的な説明になります
で 自己ベストも楽ではないということ
それは我々の普通の気持ちだと思います
だからわかってはいるんですけど
自己ベスト尽くすべきだというのは大体わかってはいるんだけど
なかなか実行になってくると大変で難しいんですね
そういう問題について考えてみたいと思います
一番大きな問題は自己ベストと言うんだけど
それって何だとわかっていないんでしょう
これが自己ベストとは何かと繰り返した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
わかっているようでわかっていないようなものです
大体人間っていうのは平気で言葉を使うんだけど
全然意味を理解しない
あまりも使いすぎになるとわかったような気がするんです
ただそれだけ だからこの言葉にすごい厳しくないんだから
なかなか頭は発展していかないんですよ
とにかく新しい単語 表現を作って作って使う
かっこいい かっこいいと思って
しかしわかってない だから自己ベストという単語も
ただ使っているだけでわかっていないんです
皆 仕事や学問 家事 子育てなどを思うでしょう
自己ベストといえば まあそういうことを思い浮かぶと思いますよ
仕事で自己ベストを尽くすとかね
学問をやるときはちゃんとベストを尽くすとか
あるいは家事の場合 子育てはね
自分のベストを尽くすとか
そういうふうになんとなく思っちゃう
それがうまくいっても自己ベストを生きることになるのでしょうか？と私は疑問を抱きたいんです
仕事はうまくいっている
だから自己ベストに生きていると言えるんですか？まあ
家事はうまくできているんだ
だったらまあ立派な人間で
完璧で問題ないと言えますかね
母親として子育てはしっかりやったんだと
それで完璧な人間だとは言えるんですか？だから
これはおかしいんです
仕事やら家事やら子育てやら
こういう日常で我々が思い浮かぶ問題がうまくいったとしても
それが自己ベストを生きるということになります
答えにならないです だからなんて言ったらなるのでしょうか
その答えはならない 理由は次のスライドで説明します
自己ベストっていうのは何なのか
人生の一部のことだけベストを尽くしても不完全です
前の幸福っていうのは人生の一部なんですよ
仕事っていうのは人生の一部でしょう
家事っていうのは人生じゃないでしょう
人生の一部でしょう 学問っていうのは人生じゃないでしょう
ただ一部でしょう だから一部をうまくいったんだからと
例えば絵画を描こうと思って
白いキャンバスだけ持ってきて
はい 終わりとならないでしょうね
白いキャンバスは絵画の場合は一部だけなんです
では 絵の具も揃ってあげるぞとかね
それで絵画にならないでしょうに
だから一部だけ一部を全体だと思うのはあまりにもおかしいんです
これをよくみんなやってるんです
一部が全体であると だからこの一部だけなんですね
それが 他のところでふざけても怠けても良いことになるんですよ
だからみんなそうでしょうね
会社で真面目に仕事をして自己ベストを尽くしている人が
人生がいい加減なんですよ
仕事終わったらもう人間じゃないんです
猿と言いたいんだけど
猿に怒られるんだから言えないんです
もう家庭なんかはむちゃくちゃで
しかし仕事になってくるとすごい立派で
だからこの一部自己ベストだと勘違いしているんだから
みんな残りの人生はふざけても怠けてもどうでもいいやと思っているんです
犯罪を起こしたってのはどうでもいいやと
これがみんなやってやっていて
人生は失敗するんですよ
だから仏教から見れば
人生は全部成功しなくちゃいけないんです
会社でいい仕事人であると言ったっても
完璧な人間にはならない
あらゆる角度から見て完全ではなければいけません
人生は生まれた時から死ぬまでの一本の流れです
人生っていうのは 生まれた時から死ぬ瞬間まで一本の流れになります
ありません どこにも 人生は
だから 会社で仕事をすることも人生で
仕事が終わって飲み屋さんの お姉ちゃんのお尻を触ることも人生なんです
だからそれがダメでもいいやというの冗談じゃないでしょう
ずっと人生はもう成功しておかないと
一部だけ成功して 一部が関西横ったりして
これトータル的に見るとむちゃくちゃでしょう
に ものすごい臭い生ゴミの捨てているところに 1本の花が咲いているんだから
なんて美しい公園でしょうかと驚くんですかね
周りが臭くても生ゴミだらけだったら
だから自己ベストっていうのは
人生は 1本の流れで見て
全部完璧に行う 会社でバリバリと仕事をしたならば
疲れて飲み屋さんに行ったならば
そちらでもすごいしっかりした人間で行動を起こす
電車に乗ったら 電車ででもしっかりした紳士らしく電車にいる
家に帰ったらしっかりした父親として家の活動もするという
そういう風にしなきゃ
だから自立した時点から死ぬ瞬間までベストを尽くすなら完全ではないでしょうかと
だから仏教でいう自己ベストっていうのはそういうことなんです
人間 赤ちゃんにはできませんだから
で 自立した時から自分で働かなくちゃいけない
だからそこからはベストを尽くさなくちゃいけないんです
ということは 何をしてもベストを尽くすべきなのですということなんですね
だから 生まれた時から死ぬまで
何をしてもベストしなくちゃいけないんです
ちょこっと人と喋る時でも
それは自己ベストでなければダメなんです
宅急便で何か品物が届いたら
これ判子を押してそれをもらうでしょうに
その瞬間でもベストを尽くさなきゃダメなんです
洗濯物を干す場合はいい加減でダメなんです
洗濯物を洗濯することも
洗濯物を干すことも ちゃんとベストを尽くさなくちゃいけないんですよ
その人は成功しないと思う
それで階段を下りる場合は
それまたベストを尽くさなくちゃいけないんです
階段を上がる時 またベストを尽くさなくちゃいけないんです
自分の人生だから それが仏教が見ているベストなんです
これが大変かどうか分かりません
それはもう皆様方はどう思うか
私はわかりませんという意味なんです
こんなのは大変やと 一部ならだったら頑張れるんだと
それだったらもう怠け者で
もうもう負け犬で決まってます
私は料理作る場合は自己ベストできますけど
それからダメですよというならば
もうダメの人間なんですよ
男はまあ仕事ならベストを尽くしますけどと
家のことになったらもうダメですよというならば
失敗者なんですよ これ大変じゃないんですけど
これはもう大変だと思う人々はいますよ
大変だと思ったらもう大丈夫です
失敗者です しかし 小さなことでもベストを尽くせば楽しいものですよ
ちょっと小さなことでもベストを尽くしちゃうと楽しいんですよ
洗濯物を干す時でも ちゃんと一回振って
そのしわをちょこっと伸ばしておいて
そのその服の形に合わせて
だってズボンなんかはこの足のところからぶら下がったっても
地面に触れたりするでしょうに
だからズボンを干す場合はどんな形かと
スカートの場合はどういうことかと
ブラウスの場合はどういうやり方かと
そこはちょこちょこっと考えて
そのそれやってもほんのつまらないことでしょ
どうったことないでしょうね
女性はすごい仕事だと思ってますけどね
それでもしっかりやったら気分がいいはずなんです
楽しいはずなんです 誰にも文句言えませんよと
自分でも気分がいいんでしょうね
だから自己ベストを尽くすっていうことは
もういかに楽しく生きるかっていうことなんですよ
これ 大変なことじゃないんです
だから気分が良い 充実感を感じる
心は穏やかになるんでしょうに
だから無知な人は自己ベストを尽くすって生きるっていうことは大変だな
これは嫌だな こんな話はと思うでしょうに
おかしいんですよ 私は聞きたいのは
あなたは楽しく生きていきたいか
あるいはものすごい不幸のどん底で
苦しんで悩んで生きていきたいのかっていうことなんです
ものすごく楽しくて 幸福で穏やかでいい気分で生きたければ
自己ベストを尽くすしかないんです
自己ベストっていうのは
小さな小さなことでも
行ってみたらものすごい気分がいいはずなんです
だから幸福っていうのは常に今ここにあるもんなんですよね
我々はそれを見逃しちゃうんですよ
一つ見逃しちゃうと 全部見逃すことになるんです
例えば 今の皆様の自己ベストっていうのは
いくら何で私の話を聞くことなんです
それは聞かないで ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃくだらない妄想ばっかりしちゃうと
講演終わってからはかなり最悪感に苛まれます
電車に乗ってもいい気分じゃないんです
こちらに私が言う新しい考え方
仏教的な考え方は 実行してもしなくても
覚えておいたならば 電車に乗った時はすごい気分がいいんです
まあいろんなことを覚えた
覚えましたよという だから自己ベストを尽くすっていうことは楽しいんです
だから大変やというのは無知な人しか言わないんです
従って自己ベストを生きるのです
ということは これ楽しいんだから
充実感感じるんだから
穏やかになるんだから
気分がいいんだからこそ
人は常に自己ベストを尽くすんです
自己ベストを生きるんです
尽くすのではなくて だからといって何をやってもいいわけじゃないんです
そこでもう一つのポイントがあるんです
だからその瞬間 その瞬間できることだから
だったら何やってもいいんじゃないかということじゃないんです
一瞬のうちにやらなくてはならないことはいくつもあるんです
これって人生なんですよ
今座ってる一瞬ででもやりたいことはいっぱい頭の中にあると思いますよ
いろいろ妄想したり 早くその話を終わってくれないかとか
帰る時は雨が降っちゃうと困ったとか
いろいろ だからそういうものを考えるか
あるいは話を聞くか あるいは寝るか
選択いくつかあるんですよ
今の時間に それってのは人生の一隅でも一個だけじゃないんですよ
よく覚えてほしいんです
こちらで この講演会で
こちらの椅子に座っていても
その瞬間ででも 自分にはやりたいことやらいっぱいあるんです
しかし 全部できませんよ
グーグーと寝ながら また妄想もしながら話も聞くと
これはありえません 寝るならば寝るだけで
話を聞かないで他のことを妄想するんだったらそれだけでいい
話を聞くんだったらそれだけで一個しかできないんですよ
しかし みんな何やるのかというと
無知な人は全部やろうとして何もできなくなる
これはみんなやってます
それ全部やろうとするんです
そうすると結果として何もやってないんです
ただ時間の無駄だけで無駄に年取っただけで
この講演の時間  2時間ぐらいで 2時間で終わろうと思ってますけど
あの 話聞かないで座っていたならば
無駄に年取っただけで
だからあの何か一つはしっかりやらなくちゃいけないんです
話には興味ないんだけど
もうせっかくもう暖かいところだから寝てやるぞと思ったら
もうそれしっかり寝ればね
本人はよく寝たという気分でもあるんだからね
それは構いません ずっと別なことを考えたいんだからといって
別なこと考えているならば
それはそれで構いません
とにかく一つしかできない
無知な人は全部やろうとする
隠れて漫画本も読みながら
私の話も理解してやるぞとかね
それであくびもしながらちょこっと居眠りでもしてやるぞとかね
同時進行でたくさんの仕事はできません
鈍感な人は焦る 後回しにする
失敗する そこで無知な人は何でもやろうとする
鈍感な人はものすごく焦っちゃうんですね
全部やろうとはしないんだけど
まあ 2つぐらいでもやろうではないかと
4つあるんだけど まあ 4つは無理だから
2つでもやろうと思っちゃうと焦るんですよ
なぜならば  1分  1瞬間で一つしかできないんです
2つできません 階段を下りながら上がることできますか？階段を下りる場合は下りることしかできませんよ
上る場合は上がる場合は上がることしかできませんよ
では やってみてください
階段を上りながら上がるということ
上りながら上がることはできます
上りながら上がるんですから
それは私の失敗です じゃあ上りながら下りるというね
すみません で 上るか下りるかどちらかなんです
だからできません 理性のある人は一つだけを選んで
そのことを完了する そこで一つの瞬間でたくさん仕事はあるんだけど
理性ある人は一つ選ぶんです
他はもうないことに それだけやる
それを完了する それが別すことなんです
だから何でもやって良いわけじゃないんです
例えば強盗することに軸別を尽くしたら困るんじゃないんですかね
人殺すことは自己ベストを尽くしたと
まるっきり見つかりませんと
犯罪犯人はと 困るでしょう
だからまあ何でもということじゃないんです
次の問題は行為の選択
選択するということが出てくるんです
理性の人はいつでも行為を選択しなくてはならないんです
だから このよく覚えておください
成功した人生を行いたければ
ものすごく楽しく生きたければ
瞬間瞬間この選択しなくちゃいけないんです
怠けてはいることできません
いつでもいくつかの仕事があるんですよ
だからずっと じゃあこれする
こうにする これにする
これにするとかね すごく早く選択していきていかなくちゃいけないんです
選択基準が必要になります
選択するためには基準が必要でしょう
基準はこれから説明します
はい これから一方的に喋ります
選択基準は必要なんですけど
もういい加減世間の基準は捨ててください
お母さんが言う基準も
会社の社長が言う選択基準も
こいつの総理が言う選択基準もすべて捨ててください
どうにもならない みんな失敗者だからね
失敗者が決める基準はいいんです
成功者が決める基準にしてほしいんです
釈尊に説かれた道徳基準を使用するのです
釈尊は成功者なんです
完全たる人格者なんです
だから釈尊が基準はこれこれやと決めてますから
まあそれには選択はないんです
成功したければ 幸福になりたければ
もう神様の言葉を言うとひどい目にあう
聞くと 人の話を聞くと
もうろくな結果はないんです
ブッダの言葉を聞いて不幸になった試しは一回でもないんです
だからみんな聞かないんです
だから一応 まあこれ仏教の話だからね
もう断言的にブッダの基準に決めてくださいということで
これ他のいろんな講演会で説明
ものすごい詳しく説明しています
基準があります 一は自分のためになるかならないかとき
選択基準  2番目は他人のためになるかならないかという選択基準
3番目は両方のためになるかならないかという選択基準
だからためになることをやればいいんです
有意義なこと 簡単でしょうに
それで勉強をやめてゲームにゲームに勤しそうと思っちゃうと
これためにならないでしょうに
だからずっと頭の中で私のためになるか
周りのためになるか みんなのためになるかという
この 3つの基準が頭の中でもう刻んでおかないと
刻むというか 刷り込んでおかないと
瞬間たりとも忘れてはいけないんですよ
これが頭の中でしっかりとインプットしてあると
その時点から完璧な人間なんです
その時点からもう成功者
失敗はひとかけらもない
世の中であらゆる悩みがありますよ
地震も起こるし もうあれこれやと
でもこの基準さえあれば失敗はしない
何があっても もう一つ基準があります
これは微妙に難しいんですけど
前の基準はすごい簡単です
貪瞋痴が増える行為の代わりに不貪不瞋痴の行為を選ぶということで
貪瞋痴の話 欲が増える行為だったらいい加減やめると
欲が減る行為だったらそれすると
怒りが増える行為だったらそれをやめる
怒りがなくす行為だったら
それをする 無知が増える行為だったらいい加減やめる
無知がなくなる行為だったら
そこを決めると だから
それですごい簡単に あの選択基準は成り立ちます
例えば今講義中なんですけど
隣の人と何かもう大根の売し方について喋った方が面白いやと思って喋っていると
その一つ基準で決めたでしょうに
それだったら まあ一応無知が増える基準というかね
欲が増える基準というかね
何か新しい料理のやり方を教えてもらったとかね
それで欲が増えるだけで
それで基準が間違ってますね
選択が間違っています
だから常に選択する場合は
貪瞋痴が増える基準を捨てて
布団不尽不痴を育てる基準にすればいい
選択すればいいんです
それが難しいと思うならば
前に言った簡単な方法があります
どちらでも 3つの条件なんです
それから優先順位 人生の
あります これが皆様に聞いても
人生の優先順位は何なのかとわからないと思います
だから聞かない で 誰もわからないんですよ
人生では何が優先でしょうかと
優先順位もわからないでよく生きているんです
だから仏教的な話をします
1輪廻を乗り越えることですよ
それは皆様方 認めても認めなくても
否定してもどうでもいいんです
これ真理なんです 地球が丸いということと同じなんです
地球が丸いと認めても認めなくてもどうでもいいんです
犬にも猫にもミミズにも地球が丸いんです
どうしようもないんです
だから 生命たるものは輪廻を乗り越えることが優先順位の第 1 なんです
わかってもわからなくても知ったもんじゃないんです
2番目は悪をやめること
悪をやめて心を育てる
心というのは悪でできてますよ
だから悪のままで感情のままで生きていたっても
もう全然何も意味がないんですよ
次に それはもうわからないというならばね
やっぱり心の汚れを落とそう
落とそうではないかと
怠けやら無知やら嫉妬やら憎しみやら
あらゆる感情 まあゆっくりでもちょっとだけでもいいんだから
じゃあ落とそう落とそうと
それが 2番目の 順ことですよ
3番目ですよ この社会や家族の要求に応じること
社会で生きているわ 家族の中で生きているわ
そういうところでみんな頼んで
いろんなことを頼むわ
で いろいろ学校にもなんか参観日の日行かなくちゃいけないわとかね
そういう社会と家族とか
そういう人々の要求に応じることっていうのは次にあるんですね
だから優先順位は １は上です ４
は自分の快楽 楽しみです
自分の肉体の快楽やら自分の楽しみに生きるということは 4番目なんです
時間があったらね 話です
時間余ったらそれもやると
それから俗世間はこれ逆にしてますね
逆さまにまず自分の快楽
それから時間が余ったら家族の面倒を見る
と それでも時間が余ったらまあ
本でも読んで ちょっとしたいい
まあしっかりした人間になろうではないかと
これすごい優先順位が低いんですね
2番目は  4番目は  1番目はなしと
それは俗世間の順位なんです
それでもわかっていないし
どういう順位があるっていうことさえ
で 正しい順位はこれなんです
だからもうこれは覚えて守るしかないんです
こういうところは断言的なんです
皆様の自由思想は聞きません
なぜならば これが真理だからね
どうしようもないんです
調べてみても発見します
同じことだと 地球が丸くないんだそうと勝手に思っても
そういう自由がないんです
丸いものは丸いんだからね
だから真理の場合になってくると
まあもう一筋しかないんです
そんなところですね 選択は
それで我々は だから俗世間では自己ベスト作ろうとは生きようと思ってますけど
結果としては自己ワーストやってます
ベストを作りたいのですが
結果はいつでも自己ワーストになっているのではと
人の能力を発揮できない原因はいくつあります
だから自己ワーストになってるんですよね
だから世界はめちゃくちゃでしょうに
うまくいってないんです
ということは 私たちにはこの自己ベストを作れないというか
能力は発揮できない 正しい選択できない
なんかいろいろ障害あるんです
それらを理解して排除しないといけません
ベストを尽くせないようになる障害物とは何でしょうか
と だから自己ベスト尽くそうと言ってやっても
自己ワーストになっちゃうということは
いろいろ障害物があるんです
障害  第1比較すること
比較する 一見なんかいいように見えますけど
ものすごい危ないんです
他人と比較して自己ベストを測る
みんなそれやってます
これが障害なんです これは大きな間違いです
というのは この世で同一人物は 2人いません
皆様とまるっきり 100%同じ
誰かクローン人間でもいますか？いないでしょう
自分一人だけでしょう
だから自分というのは唯一な存在で
似ているものは一人もいません
それどうやって比べるんですかね
似ていないんだから これはカラスと自分と比べることと同じでしょうに
カラスと自分が比べてどちらがかっこいいか
どうやって判断するんですかね
まるっきり違うもんだから
それでカラスは唇がかっこいいなとかね
唇じゃない くちばしはいいなとか
じゃあくちばしがないんだ
かっこ悪いとかなりたたないでしょうに
だから人と比べること自体がものすごい論理的な間違いなんです
論理的と言ったっても心理的な間違いなんです
一人一人生命はユニークで
他人とは似てないんです
誰と比較するのでしょうかと
結果として劣等感も優越感も生まれてくるんですよ
くだらん 比較してね 例えばカラスと比較する
カラスには手がないんだぞとかね
私は手がある ほら 私は偉いでしょうと
くだらん考え方でしょうに
あるいはカラスは翼があって飛べるな
私は飛べないなと言って劣等感もある
くだらんでしょうに これで我々
他人と比べて劣等感やら優越感やらあるならば
もう失敗者に決まってます
その人の自己ベストは尽くせません
自己ベストを行ってない証拠です
もし落ち込んだり 劣等感に悩ませたり
あるいは優越感でいるならば
自己ベストはやってないんです
間違ったところで比較しているのです
他人と比べたベストは自己ベストではありません
覚えてください 他人と比べて決めるベストは決してベストじゃないんです
ただおかしいだけ  です
カラスと比べて カラスより私は立派に歩けるんだぞとか
私はベスト尽くしてるんだと
カラスにできないんだと言っても
それはベストじゃないでしょうに
カラスは歩くときはあまりかっこよくないんですけど
人間の目から見ても だからですよ
それはカラスの歩き方で
だから 隣の人と比べて
学校の仲間と比べて 会社の仲間と比べて
自分がベストを尽くしているんだそうと言ったら
その人はベストを尽くしてないんです
これすごい間違いなんです
そういったような この間
木曜日の瞑想会でどなたか質問したんですけどね
いろいろ世の中でね すごい優れていると言って
20%ぐらいで 他の 80%はまあそれほどまあその他大勢でということでね
まあそれで私の答えはね
それでいいんだと 人間が二人も同じじゃないんだから
それでいいんでしょうし
医学部に入れる人々は医学部に入ればよろしいし
だから言って日本の子供はみんな医学部に入るべきそうというのはおかしいんです
有名なもう大学病院の大教授と
そこら辺でもう大根作っている農業をやっているおじいさんと
誰が偉いんですかね なんで比較するんですかね
それぞれ自分のベストを尽くせばいいでしょうに
いくら偉い大学病院の教授でいたっても食わなくちゃいけないんだから
それだったらあのおじいさん作る大根になるでしょうに
いくらなんでもおじいさんが病気になっちゃうとお医者さん
医者さん お医者さんのところに行かなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから自分の立場はどうでもいいんでしょうし
その立場の中の自己ベストなんです
これ なかなかみんな理解しないんでしょうね
他人になりきることが自己ベストだと思いますよ
それっていうのはもうインチキでしょ
それはストリートパフォーマンスやってる人々やればいいんです
大道芸人たちは なんで大道芸人になることを自己ベストと言うんですかね
だから自分がある会社で掃除ばっかりやってるんだ
それでいいんでしょうに
その会社の社長がすごい事務所があって
そちらで仕事をしてるんで
それは勝手にやればいいでしょうに
それぞれ自分のベストを尽くしてほしいんです
人と比べるとすごい気持ち悪くなっちゃって
私は勉強できなかったんだから
この会社の掃除係になっているんだと
あの人はもう本当に社長になって羨ましいやとかね
そんなことを妄想すると
自分が仕事をしてないんですね
だから いかなる場合でも人と比べないことなんです
それ障害 第2自己観察しないこと
人とは比べるんだけど
自分何者かと見ないんですね
まず自分が何者かとちゃんとしないと
自分が真剣か ふざけているのか
ごまかしているのか 他人を騙そうとしているのか
観察しなくてはならないんでしょう
だから 自分が仕事をしている上で
生きている上でごまかしているんでしょうかとか
今の瞬間でふざけているんでしょうかとか
今の瞬間で人を騙せているんでしょうかとか
そうやって自分の観察すると自己ベストになるんです
自分の良心に従って生きているのかないかは観察しなくてはならない
それはすごい大事なんです
良心 この感じでしょうかね
コンシャスというのは
人間にはコンシャスということがありますね
良心というものは ちゃんと良心に合わせて比較しなくちゃ
他人と比較するんじゃないんです
自分の良心に比較してみる
比較ではなくて もう対処してみるんです
だから人間は良心に合うように生きていれば
それが自己ベストなんです
自分が素直に充実感を感じているのかないかは観察しなくてはならないんです
次のポイントは 本当に私は生きること楽しいか
充実感で生きているのかと
それに気をつけてほしい
何やっても充実感があるかないかとチェックしなくちゃいけない
充実感感じたらベストやってるんです
どんなつまらない仕事でも
どんなつまらないことでも
やった時点で楽しかったら
これ自己ベストなんです
そういうことで 自己観察っていうのをしないんだから
みんな自己ベストじゃなくて自己ワーストになってるんです
次のポイント 障害 第3 妄想
妄想は能力を壊す代物です
妄想しますよ みんな でもこれは人の能力を壊す代物でしょうし
妄想すると現実離れになるので
有意義な行為はできなくなる
妄想した時点で現実離れなんです
そうすると有効な生き方はできなくなっちゃうんです
効率的に 能率的に 有意義な生き方はできなくなるんです
ほんの一分妄想したってもダメなんです
妄想だけなら自己ベストですが
それでは精神的な病にかかるんですよ
誰でも妄想するところは自己ベストやってます
だからほとんど精神的な病気なんです
だって真剣に妄想するんだから
それまた喜んでいるでしょ
自分の妄想で だから精神的な病気なの
仏教から見ればみんなもう病気なんですよ
だから妄想っていうのはものすごいダメなもんで
もう 1 分だけでも妄想しちゃって
その 1 分人生失敗する
心を軽くして 心の柔軟性を保たなくてはならない
だから妄想するんじゃなくて
何も妄想しないで心軽いでしょ
何もいらんこと考えてない場合はすごい気持ちは軽くて
それから心はすごい柔軟性があって
何でもできそう状態になるんです
で 頭に考え方が入った途端
何でもできそうっていうことがなくなっちゃうんです
本当は心には何でもできるんですよ
しかし 我々の頭は硬いんです
あるパターンで妄想しているんだから
それが人格向上にもつながる
妄想しないんだったら人格向上にもつながる
何でもできる 心は軽い
心は柔軟性があるんだったら
毎日人格向上にもなります
これは第3番目の障害なんですね
また終わってないんで
障害は 第4番目の障害は期待
希望 計画なんです 簡単に夢の世界になりがちですので
計画を立てても具体性
論理性 実践性を忘れてはならないんです
よくみんなもう期待はあるわ
希望があるわ こんなのはもう一人歩きするんでしょうね
期待やら希望やら計画でもいくらでも書けるでしょ
紙の上で 例えば建築でもね
1本の柱の上で巨大なお城を建てるとか
紙の上では描けますよ
でも実際には作れませんけどね
だから計画 期待 希望っていうのは
すぐ夢の世界に 妄想の世界に行くんだから
気をつけなくちゃいけない
たまたまちょこちょことあってもいいんだけど
希望やらね 期待とかね
願望とか計画とかね それなりにあっても悪くないんでしょうし
しかし 具体性が必要なんです
論理性が必要なんです
実践的であること いわゆる実効性かな
実現できるかないか だから実現できない希望
願望っていうのはきれいさっぱり捨ててください
実現実現できそうだなと思ったら
まあ覚えておいてもいいんです
いつか実現できる可能性ありますから
だからこれがすごい自己ベストと化しちゃうんですよ
この計画 希望 期待っていうのは
何かの期待 計画などがうまくいったとしても
それは自己ベストとは言い切れません
まあ時々希望叶う時もありますよ
希望叶ったんだからで
自分が自己ベストを尽くしたと言わないでください
他人のおかげで期待が叶うこともありますからね
環境のおかげで 例えばオートバイ買いたいとすごく希望があって
それで親のお金狙ってオートバイ買って
私の希望は叶います と
私は自己ベストやと 冗談じゃないでしょ
だからたまたま我々の期待希望叶う時はありますが
それが自己ベスト尽くしているんだからじゃないんですよ
ただ条件が揃っただけ
だから希望叶うことで自己ベストは違うんです
自分が無理をすることもある
それから希望期待あるとで
ド派手な計画なんかあると人は無理をするんでしょう
高級なブランドのカバン買いたいんだから
もう半年ほど1年間分割払いでお金払って買うとかね
無理していますよ それ自己ベストじゃないんです
もし人が無理をして生きてるんだったら
この人は無知であって失敗者なんです
自己ベストする人は無理をしない
水分企画 水分穏やか まあたまに何か人のためにちょこちょこっと無理をするのは悪くないんだけど
無理をすること自体が正しいわけではないんです
だから言いたいのは 自己ベストを生きるためには
決して無理だけはしないでください
無理をしちゃうと それが自己ベストではありません
それは妄想に踏ん張っているんです
第5番目の障害 頑張る
無理をするということ
やみくもに頑張ること
無理をすることはかっこよいと勘違いしています
やみくもに頑張る 無理をしているんだと
なんか自分でかっこいいことをやっていると思っています
結果がダメですけどね
ダメな人間という証拠です
それが 無理をしてるんだからダメに決まってるでしょうに
ただやみくもにやってるんだったら
頭が悪いに決まってるでしょうに
努力は実用主義的でなくてはならないんです
努力してはいけないっていうのは
仏教でそんな話ないんだから
努力はする 頑張ったりもする
たまに踏ん張ったりもする
たまたま無理もする しかし
いつでも実用主義でなければいけません
結果があるかないか うまくいっているかないかと
期待する何かを叶えるためなら無理をする必要もあるが
無理をすることはベストではありません
まあ時々無理をすることもありますよ
人生の中で 何か期待があります
何かやりたいことがあって
それだったらそこを少々そこら辺で期待叶うまでは無理をする
しかし だからといってそれは自己ベストということになりません
だから一生無理をするんじゃないんですね
一生もう何といいますか
やみくもにやるんじゃなくて
まあ時によって 場合によって
ここら辺はちょこっと無理をしないとどうかいけませんとか
例えば山を登っていて
あと 20 メートルしかない
もう最後になってくると
かなりあれね もう なんて言いますか
険しいんだからね それが厳しいんだから
ここまで登ってきたんだからね
じゃあちょこっとこの 20 メートルは無理をしましょうと
そうすればちょうどだから
そういうふうな感じだったらね
問題ないんですけど 特に日本ではこのやみくもにやること
無理をしてやることは偉い
なんかすごい道徳というか
すごい なんて言いますか
あれは美徳ですね だから無知は美徳にしているんです
失敗することは美徳にしているだけ
6番目の障害 感情または煩悩ですね
エネルギーを浪費して能力を低下させる
感情やら煩悩が出てくると
エネルギーは浪費して能力が低下します
集中力がなくなるんです
で 感情っていうのは欲
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 競争心
見栄 傲慢 怠け 落ち着きがない
興奮状態 無知 そういうものなんですね
そういうものは大体煩悩千序百もありますからね
まあ一応たくさんあります
もう心が硬いことも 人の話を聞かないことも煩悩の一つで
わがままも煩悩の一つでいっぱいありますけど
そういうもので能力は低下するんです
集中力がなくなるんです
また 自我中心的な生き方
それも煩悩の一つなんですね
まあそういう まあ長く言っちゃった
で まあ感情煩悩ということでね
まあこれを覚えておいてください
感情煩悩が割り込むと
自己ベストはできなくなるんです
能力なくなっちゃいますからね
で  7番目に行きます  7番目の障害は恐怖感
怯え 恐れなどです 結構見覚えあると思いますけど
怯え 恐怖感などを感じると何もできなくなるんです
大体大体ほとんどの人々はなんとなく不安で怯えているんでしょうしね
これは危ないんでしょうし
別に何か怯えているんでしょうかね
だから仏教ではね まず死を観察しなさいと
人っていうのはどんな瞬間でも死ぬことはできますね
死ねちゃう 死ねちゃうしね
だから一番この我々の命っていうのは
なんか水風船みたいなもんでしょうね
風船に空気入れたらいくらが頑丈なんですけど
水入れちゃうとすぐ弾けちゃいます
そんな感じで 体っていうのはすぐ壊れてしまう脆いもんですよ
体ほど脆いものはないんですよ
だからそれはしっかりと覚えて
覚悟して納得していくと
恐怖感がなくなっちゃうんです
別に何に怖いんでしょうか
そうすると明るく生きていられます
自分に対して自信がない人
自分を大事にしない人がよく頼りになる逃げ道なんです
自信がない人は何か言い訳がないとダメでしょ
だからなんか分からないんだけど
えらい恐怖感を感じているんだと
人を見ると怖くなるんだとか
外を出ると怖くなるんだそうと言って逃げるんです
自信がないだけ だからそれから自分を大事にしない人も
自分に対してすごい不親切でいい加減で
そういう人々もかなり恐怖感があるんだということで逃げるんですね
非論理的な不安感 また不安不安だと言うんですけど
何が何で不安でしょうかと聞いたらわからないでしょうに
だったらいい加減捨てた方がいいんでしょうね
答えは仏教的にありますよ
すべては無常なので 不安だというだと思うことと違う
無知な感情ですよ 仏教的にも不安感生まれます
それは一切は無常であると
だから安定した境地はどこにもないんだよと
なんでも変わるんだよと
あの今日のテレビ番組出たような
この視線を戻ろうと思ったって
戻りくはないんです すべて変化している
あの教授が頑張って頑張って
20年  20年後で あるいは 40年後で
あの昔の視線関係に戻ったからといって
当時できている人ほど
それは喜ぶかないかわからないでしょうに
だからすべて不安だと見るのは仏教的なんですけど
それは論理性ですよ 普通の人間はそうじゃなくて
わけのわからないんだけど
不安感があるんだと それは精神的な病気で
すぐ忘れた方がいいんです
忘れる方法っていうのは
人っていうのはちょっとしたことで死ぬもんだから
まあ死ぬことほど怖いことないでしょうに
それは目の先のにあるんだから
他はどうったことないんでしょう
例えば高いところを見たら
ああ 不安だと 怖いんだと
死ぬことほど冗談ことないでしょうに
そういうことであらゆる恐怖感がなくなるんです
それでだいたい終わりますけどね
それでベストなのかということ
自分がベストを過ごしているのか否かは他人にはわかりません
覚えてください これ結論にあります
今日の話の自分がベストを尽くしているかないか
他人にはわかりません
他人にとっては 頼んだ仕事をしっかりやってもらえば十分ですからね
たとえお母さんにしても
子供に何か頼んだら 頼んだことをやってもらえば
お母さんがうちの子はもう自己ベストやってるんだぞと言いながらね
これはベストじゃないんです
他人というのは 頼んだ仕事をやってもらえば
まあそれで十分ですから
他人の他人が欲張ってもっと頑張れという可能性もあるんです
例えば子供はしっかり宿題やったら
お母さんが欲張っちゃって
もっと頑張れと それってのは大きな迷惑でしょうね
子供は自己ベストじゃなくて
無理をして宿題したならばどうします？無理までしてやったのに
お母さんが欲張っちゃって
もっと頑張れと言うと話にならないんでしょう
ですから 他人にわからない
自分が自己ベストですかないかということは
他人に頼っちゃうと無理をさせちゃうんでしょうし
会社で自分が自己ベスト仕事をしたら
社長がこれではダメです
もっと頑張れと平気で言うんでしょう
もう来年はもっとあと 3万
3,000万円収入を上げなくちゃいけないんだとかね
そんな無知な社長だから
会社っていうのは平気で倒産するでしょうに
いとも簡単に 自己ベストに挑戦する人は
俗世間の評価に左右されない
自己ベストっていうのは世間言うことじゃないんです
これは自分の問題なんです
だから 世間があなたはベストを尽くしてないんだよと言ったっても
別に気にすることはない
あるいはあなたはすごいベストを尽くしているんだと言われても
それも本当のことじゃないんです
自己ベストは自分にしかわからないんです
ですから 自分に正直に素直になる必要があります
だから 自己ベストをやりたければ
自分に正直になってください
すごく素直になってください
道徳的でないベストは罪なので
猛毒のごとく避けるべきです
その時も一義を入れておかないとね
素直に罪を犯してもダメなんです
それは罪ですからね ベストを尽くしたか否かは
充実感 幸福感 満足感でわかるんですよ
自分が幸福感 充実感を感じているんだったら
もうベストやってます
無理はしていないんです
無理しちゃうと幸福感を感じないんですよ
達成感という言葉もありますけどね
それ感じるんだったら
もうベストやってます
それから成功の秘訣 自分に素直になる
大胆なスケールの計画は立てない
人生を極端に短いコマに切る
だから瞬間単位に人生を切ってみるんです
今の行為だけに集中してそれを行う
次のことどうでもいいんです
今のことだけやればいいんです
憎い相手に頼まれた仕事であっても
半端にいい加減にしたら恥ずかしいのは自分ですよ
例えば 嫌な人に仕事を頼まれる
ろくにお金も払ってくれない
そうすると半端でもいい加減やりたくなるでしょうに
やってはいけません 自分が恥ずかしいんでしょう
これってのはよくあるんでしょう
収入はあまり足らない場合は
仕事はいい加減にする
仕事を頼んだ人は嫌な人だったら
もう嫌な人になんか料理作ってくれませんかというと
随分手抜きでいい加減な料理を作る
そうするとあんた料理下手やと言われるんだからね
結局失敗するのは自分なんですよ
だから自分の仕事はお金くれてもくれなくても
嫌な人に頼まれても たとえ敵に頼まれても
自分がベストを尽くすんです
態度を大事にする それどういう意味かというと
態度を大事にするんです
これが秘訣ですよ 自己ベストを尽くすために
それからブッダの言葉
これまた神々のエピソードが入ります
アシュラのヴェーローチナっていう神がね
これアシュラですね 帝釈神と帝釈天がブッダの前で説いた言葉です
ある日 お釈迦様がいるところに
このヴェーローチナという阿修羅の神も帝釈天も来たんですよ
来て 両側にお釈迦様のところに立っていて
お釈迦様と話したんですね
お互いいろいろ発言があったんです
それでヴェーローチナさんはこう言うんです
わやめてえはプリソヤーアッタッサニッパダニッパンナソーヴァのアットヴェーローチャナワチョイダン
ヴェーローチナさんがなんかかっこいい言葉言ってやるぞと言って言ったんですよ
かっこいい言葉はわやめてえはプリソ
人間というのは精進するんだよと
精進するものであって
ヤーアッタッサニッパダ目的に達するまで
目的を達成するまで諦めず頑張るもんだよ
ニッパンナソーヴァのアット
それで目的に達したら
それこそ素晴らしいんだと
そう思うの この達成感が素晴らしいんだと
ヴェーローチャノワチョイダン
これはヴェーローチャナの言葉ですと
なんか自分の名前まで書くんです
サインしているんです
それ帝釈天の意味はね
目的が叶うまで人は努力する
目的に達した方が素晴らしいとヴェーローチャナが言うという意味なんですね
これ帝釈天の言葉 同じです
わやめてえはプリソヤーアッタッサニッパダニッパンナソーヴァのアットカンテアビーヨネビッジャティ
で 人はやっぱり目的達するまで頑張るんだ
同じこと言うんです ニッパンナソーヴァの
あと 何か頑張ったらならば達成感
達しなきゃダメやと だから私は前に言ったこの実用主義
効率っていうのは 仏教はすごい気をつけるんです
ただ頑張ったんだから
ご苦労様っていうのはもうもう褒め言葉じゃないんです
あれはあんたダメやって意味なんです
日本では 私は最初に聞いたら
あれ嫌な言葉だなと思ったんです
仏教から見ると あれはもう人をけなしたことなんだ
ご苦労さんと だって何の意味もないということでしょうね
まあまあ 別に日本ではそう思ってないんだけど
なんか文字だけ見ると
ご苦労さんっていうのはなんか人を馬鹿にしているんです
だから自分がやった仕事でちゃんと結果があるならば
ご苦労様と言っても それは気持ち違うんです
本当にご苦労様でした
よく頑張れ よく助かりましたっていう言葉でしょうし
だからただご苦労さんと言われるために頑張るんだったらもうダメですよ
だからこの実用主義というか
この効率をはかるという仏教の立場をよく覚えてください
こちらで言っているのはそういうことなんです
一般の僧侶も結果出さなきゃダメやと
だから結果が出るまで頑張るんだよと
しかし これ 帝釈天がヴェーローチナ阿修羅神に対して対立して言ってることだから
彼が自分のサインしないんです
サインは代わりに別なことを言うんです
これ カンティアビーヨネリッジェティ
カンティっていうのはこの忍耐
忍耐ですね なんか意味がわからなくなっちゃうんですね
忍耐ほどすごいことはありませんと帝釈天をつなげるんです
それどういうことかというと
目的に達するためには忍耐がね
結構必要なんです 忍耐がないとすぐ諦めちゃうんですよ
だから帝釈天いうのは
人は目的に達するまで頑張るもんだよと
なぜならば目的に達した方が素晴らしいんだよと
しかし 忍耐はこれが必須だと
とても必要なものであると
だからヴェーローチナさんよりは帝釈天の言葉はちょこっと上なんです
頭いいんです 帝釈天はどうしても仏教は代表するんだから
阿修羅神はそれほどでもないんです
俗世間代表するんです
これ サンケットに代わりに出てくるんです
ということで この我々は忍耐ということ
諦めないということをね
少々の苦しみをね 気にしないということね
必要なんです それから自己ベストの意味
自分自身に勝つこと 負けないことです
自己ベストっていうのは自分に負けないことでしょうに
だって他人に比べませんだからね
自分に負けてはあかん
心は汚れていて 希望通りには生きていられない
一応普通はね 心は汚れてるんだから
何一つも希望通りにいけないんですよ
心は 汚れてないんだったら
希望通りに生きてられます
心の汚れを 何だったんかね
うん あ これ性でなんですね
まあ心は汚れてるんだから
まあ私たちはやってることは正しいか間違ってる
わからないでしょ？皆さんはそうでしょ
自分たちは毎日頑張ってるんだけど
それでいいのか悪いのか
良かったか悪かったかわからないでしょ
結果が出てるとわかりますけど
その時も遅いでしょ 子育ては間違ったとか
もうもうどうしようもないね
それ その場合は終わったことだから
だからそれっていうのは
人間にとってはすごいハンディでしょうし
障害でしょうし やる前にあ
これが正しい これが間違っていると知っていれば最高なのにね
やってからはあれをやらなかった方がよかったとね
わかっては意味がないんですね
これっていうのは心の汚れだからわからないんでしょうに
だからみんな生きかばちか分からなくて
行動しなくちゃいけないんでしょうし
常に人の評価は気になる
それで人間のもう一つの欠点は
人の評価は気になるんですね
他人に求めることを 認めることを求める
馬鹿に認めてもらったって意味がないしね
本当はブッダに褒められるように生きるべきなんですけど
それから人っていうのは自分の気持ちに反する行動をするんでしょ
だから自分に勝ってほしいんです
もう一度前のところを考えた方がいいと思いますけど
自己ベストっていうのは
こういう我々に問題があるんですね
だから これは自分に負けてる証拠なんで
例えば人の評価気にするんだったら
自分にはなんか自信がないってことでしょ
人の評価気にいって気になってしょうがないと
もう失敗するんでしょう
自分に負けてるんです
だからあんたよく頑張ったと言ってくれると
もう舞い上がっちゃうんです
人にそんなこと言ってくれなくてもいいでしょうに
だから自分に負けている
自分が負けていると思っているのに
人が褒めてくれると ああ
そうか よかったんですねと我ながらと思うのはおかしいでしょうに
だから人が何と言おうとも関係ない
自分がベストを尽くしているならば
自信があるんでしょうし
でも人間そうじゃないんです
自分に負けてるんです
自分に負けてるんだから
こういう風なことよく起こる
何かやってはいるんだけど
これでいいか悪いかわからない
心は汚れている 人の評価を気にするとかね
だから自分に勝ちなさいという答えなんです
自分に勝った方が自己ベストなんです
で ブッダの言葉 アッターハゲジタンセジョヤーチャーヤンイタラーパジャ
ヤーチャーヤンイタラーパジャというのは
そこらへんにいる人々なんていう意味なんで
そこら辺にいるその他大勢の人々よりも
アッターハゲジタンセイ自分に勝った方が素晴らしいんだと
アッタダンタッサポーサッサ
自分を制御して戒めた人
ニッチャンサンネタカーリの
常に落ち着いて穏やかな生き方をする人の勝利は
ネーワデーヴォナガンダッボ
神であろうが ガンダッバっていうのはなんとか知らない神霊なんです
で ガンダッバであろうが
マーラ悪魔であろうか
ブラフマー梵天であろうか
ジタンアパジタンカイラ
その勝利は あの なんて言いますか
えっ くそひっくり返す
覆すことはできませんと
だから自分に勝ったならば
自分に勝って 心穏やかで落ち着いて自己制御して生きている
自分で自分に勝っている
自分の気持ちに反することをしない
その人の勝利は覆すことは誰にもできません
たとえ神が出てきたって
たとえ悪魔が出てきたって何もできません
それは最高たる勝利なんですね
意味は人に勝つより自分に勝つことが優れている
生き方を戒めて自己制御している人の勝利は
たとえ神々にもガンダッブたちにも
マーラにも梵天にも敗北にすることはできません
それで敗北は正しい言葉わかりませんだけど
一応繰り返すことはできません
悪 絶対的な勝利 では どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます